la coulée verte un lieu de promenade à
voisins le bretonneux transformé en
camping de fortune depuis le 7 juin une
communauté catholique de gens du voyage
s'est installée illégalement sur ce
terrain appartenant à saint quentin en
yvelines
la ville n'a pas eu d'autre choix que de
les laisser la police nationale à
l'ordre en direct du préfet de laisser
faire puisque des ternes qui ont été
rapportés à m'ont élu c'est un moindre
mal puisque je crois qu'avec le golfe
ils essaient de protéger un petit peu
les alentours le quarantenaire on n'a
pas le choix c'est la loi la loi ne nous
est pas parce qu une forte l'écart
avalant des télés on ne peut plus les
voiliers la mairie a donc mis à
disposition des conteneurs et des
branchements en eau et électricité pour
la soixantaine de caravanes
mais dans ce quartier résidentiel de la
bretonnière avec une école les
inquiétudes sont nombreuses
les habitants sont excessivement
remontée et il ya de quoi
je crois que nous sommes dans une
situation un peu inhabituel
le cadre de vie levy sinois ils sont
profondément attachés et là on voit des
gens un groupement massif s'installer il
ya dégradation de terrain je souhaitais
que le thé que les terras le terrain
soit nettoyé bien évidemment contacté
par nos soins la communauté n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer
le responsable s'est engagé auprès de la
mairie à partir le 23 juin et à nettoyer
les lieux avant leur départ